on Monday a total eclipse will travel
coast-to-coast for the first time in 99
years NASA scientists will use specially
equipped aircraft to get an up-close
view David Pegg no is at NASA's
ellington Field in Houston with this
ambitious airborne experiments
David Jeff good morning from the South
the pilots flying these NASA aircrafts
and there will be two of them will be
flying at 50 thousand feet above the
clouds and above any kind of atmospheric
turbulence there will be two guys on
board you got the pilot in the front and
the operator in the back he's the man
that's gonna be controlling the joystick
to get the photos and to get that
they've taken the nose cone off this old
bomber plane and outfitted it with a
precise telescopic lens that's going to
help NASA unlock some of the secrets of
the Sun it's go time for NASA's
stratospheric airborne science team
these pilots at ellington Field next
door to Johnson Space Center in Houston
are going on an atmospheric research
flight their ride is a 1960s era former
bomber jet called The WB 57
during Monday's total solar eclipse
these same planes will serve a very
different purpose you're not wearing the
moon suit but you have to wear the
Eclipse glasses right yeah it's actually
even more important to wear the Eclipse
glasses at high altitudes there's less
air to block the Sun and the sun's a lot
stronger Carrie Klem is one of four NASA
flight crew members who will be chasing
the Eclipse over Missouri Illinois and
Kentucky at four hundred and sixty miles
per hour my job is to calibrate and
initialize the camera payload that we'll
be using to look at the eclipse that
includes focusing and zooming in to get
the best shot you don't get a plane ride
unfortunately I don't get a plane ride
but the Amir Casspi will lead the team
of scientists these planes will be
outfitted with special cameras in their
nose cones so the planes will be looking
at the solar corona the outer atmosphere
of the Sun during a regular day the sky
is so bright you can't see the corona
but during a total solar eclipse that
dim Corona suddenly becomes visible our
results will lead to a better
understanding of the corona which will
eventually lead to a better
understanding of flares and coronal mass
ejections which affects the public how
they can cause blackouts of radio
frequency communications cellphones can
have trouble working it can cause power
outages by knocking out power grids the
best way to understand what erupts off
the Sun's corona is to photograph it
over long periods of time but
ground-based cameras will only have
about two minutes of the total eclipse
time because two of these planes will be
flying tandem right along the Eclipse
path it will give these scientists and
unprecedented look at our Sun each plane
will be able to observe totality for
about four minutes and when we stitch
together the observations from both of
the airplanes will be getting 30
photographs a second for seven and a
half minutes of totality
that's about 29,000 photographs between
the two airplanes fascinating right so
Monday on CBS we will be showing you
live images from this aircraft in real
time as the Eclipse is happening Nora do
you know that it 50 thousand feet where
this pilots gonna be it's 20 to 30 times
darker up there than it will be for the
rest of us on
you know what David I did not know that
no I did not but now I do because David
tells us things that we did not bingo
previously how we all know point you
reach a level of dark though where you
can't get any darker right probably
tried well you can see the stars we'll
talk about this later all right